la parole est maintenant notre collègue
dominique de legge pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministères collègues ma
question s'adresse au ministre de la
famille
pour la première fois depuis de
nombreuses années la france qui assurait
le renouvellement de ces générations ne
l'a surplus avec vingt mille naissances
en moins en 2015
ma question est simple dames la ministre
pensez vous qu'un lien puisse être
établi entre les mesures du gouvernement
augmentation de la fiscalité des ménages
conjugué à la baisse continue du
quotient familial réforme des conditions
d'attribution des prestations familiales
et les résultats démographique nous
connaissons et si oui
envisagez vous de revenir sur les
mesures qui se sont traduites par une
baisse du pouvoir d'achat des familles
de plusieurs milliards merci pour vous
répondre
la parole est à madame laurence
rossignol secrétaire d'état en charge de
la famille de l'enfance et des personnes
âgées vous avez la parole madame la
ministre monsieur le sénateur de lécher
vous me posez une question simple est-ce
que je pense qu'il ya un lien entre la
politique familiale conduite par le
gouvernement et la baisse de 20 mille
naissances au cours d'un 2015 ma réponse
sera aussi clair non non d'abord s'en
vouloir
voilà non sans vouloir transformer
l'hémicycle en cours de svt la réforme
des modulations la modulation des
allocations familiales s'est appliquée
au 1er juillet 2015
donc j'ai du mal à croire que cette
réforme est impacté le nombre de
naissances en 2015 je vous rappelle que
malgré une accélération globale des
modes de vie le temps de grossesse est
toujours de neuf mois plus serré plus
sérieusement si nous voulons comprendre
ce qu'il se passe analysons d'abord le
taux de fécondité qu'il ne faut pas
confondre avec le taux de natalité le
mais vous pouvez rire monsieur monsieur
sy diop non ne riez pas pas vous pas
encore vous et le taux de fécondité
c'est le nombre d'enfants qu'une femme
en âge de procréer mais au monde
ce taux de fécondité reste aujourd'hui à
1,96 enfants par femme en france c'est
le taux de fécondité le plus élevé
d'europe
en revanche il y a à peu près une
vingtaine d'années le nombre de
naissances a baissé et ce sont 300 mille
femmes en âge de procréer qui manquent à
l'appel
vingt ou trente ans plus tard donc pour
faire simple nous avons moins de femmes
en âge de faire des bébés aujourd'hui
qu'il y en avait il y a quinze ans donc
bien entendu ça impacte le nombre de
naissances sans impacter le taux de
fécondité
par ailleurs la tête mais ne riez pas
c'est lise et lisez les conclusions de
l'ined
lisez ce que disait démographe et ce qui
compte c'est combien les familles
mettent d'enfants au monde aujourd'hui
par rapport au nom de famille ça ne
change pas enfin la politique familiale
du gouvernement est une politique qui
vise à la fois à réorienter les
prestations enfin en faveur des familles
les moins favorisées vous et vous vous
évoquez souvent l'évolution des familles
la plus importante c'est celle des
familles monoparentales
il faut qu'aujourd'hui qui aujourd'hui
concentre toute la pauvreté et qui est
notre priorité
merci monsieur de lège
madame la ministre je vous parle de
politique familiale
mais vous me répondez politique sociale
visiblement nous n'avons pas tout à fait
la même conception de la politique
familiale pour vous elle est en quelque
sorte un sous produit de la politique
sociale est un instrument de régulation
des comptes sociaux
pour nous c'est un investissement au
profit de la nation toute entière
madame l'ami je vous rejoins pour
considérer qu effectivement il n'y a pas
une adéquation entre le taux de natalité
et le volume des aides accordées aux
familles mais dans ce domaine il en va
comme dans le domaine économique
ce qui est important c'est de créer un
climat favorable un climat favorable à
l'économie mes chers collègues s'étaient
effectivement de respecter les
entreprises ne donnent pas les taxer et
bien ce que je constate ce que je
constate chers collègues ne vous en
déplaise c'est qu'il y a toujours eu un
consensus en france autour de la
politique familiale
quels que soient les gouvernements et ce
consensus vous la conclure et tous les
indicateurs économiques sont au rouge
que ce soit le chemin pur que ce soit le
budget que ce soit la dépense publique
et maintenant voici que le taux de
natalité comme son concurrent rouge je
crois que ce point de vue vous ne
participez pas une police